[موسيقى]
عندما أخبر الناس أنني مصارع
إذا لم يصدقوني حقًا في البداية ،
فأنا لا أعرف الصورة التي لديهم في
رؤوسهم لما يجب أن يبدو عليه المصارع
خاصة عندما أقول إنني
الوزن الثقيل جدًا ، لذا فإن صلصة الليمون
تبدو وكأنها تصارع
وكأنك جميلة جدًا لدرجة أنك لا تستطيع المصارعة
ولذا فمن المثير دائمًا أن تجعلها
مثل ما كنت تتوقعه
[موسيقى]
اسمي adilyn grey أنا
بطل العالم ثلاث مرات في المرتبة الأولى في
العالم لم يهزم لمدة عامين ونصف
ولم أفكر أبدًا في
الألعاب الأولمبية كخيار بالنسبة لي عندما كنت
طفلاً أصغر سنًا ، وهو شيء
لا أعتقد أن هناك عددًا كافيًا من الفتيات لديهن
فرصة  أحلم
بأني أريد إعادة تعريف المؤنث إلى
حد ما وأن أجعل الناس
يتحدون الطريقة التي ينظرون بها إلى كلمة قوية
وليس مجرد رؤية فتى ينبثق في
رأسك ،
لقد بدأت في مصارعة الأولاد كنت في السادسة
من عمري وصارعت الأولاد جميعًا  من
خلال المدرسة الثانوية وأعتقد أنني
كسبت الكثير  من الاحترام من الكثير من
زملائي في الفريق الذين خسروا أمامي
أو ربما هزموني وحصلت على تدريب
مع أفضل اللاعبين في العالم
وجعلوني أكثر صرامة وجعلوني أعمل في
كل نقطة كان عليّ أن أتصارع معها
وقد فعلوا ذلك حتى أتمكن من أن
أكون بطلة على مستوى السيدات الآن
نعلم الفتيات أن يكونن مثاليات والأولاد أن
يخاطروا ، أحتاج إلى المخاطرة
بأنني امرأة قوية واثقة من
أنني أعرف أنني بارعة في المصارعة.  ما زلت
أعاني من هذا المفهوم الذي أشعر
بالقلق بشأن عدم كوني مثالية عندما
أمشي على السجادة
[موسيقى
] يجب أن أخطو على تلك السجادة وأتأكد
من أنني أعمل في كل لحظة للفوز
بميدالية ذهبية أولمبية
[موسيقى]
أريد أن تكون الفتيات الصغيرات قادرات على النظر إلى
وضعي هذا وأن يحلمن
به ، أنا متحمس لتلك اللحظة لأن
أرتفع من أعمالي الخمسة وأن أكون قادرًا على
معرفة أنني سأحمل ميدالية ذهبية
حول رقبتي
[  موسيقى]